einen wunderschönen guten tag hier aus
strande in schleswig holstein bei kiel
ich sitze im lieblingslokal von wolfgang
kubicki dem fdp vize chef und in seinem
wohnort in strande wolfgang kubicki
schöne aussicht hier was würden sie
jetzt normalerweise tun
normalerweise ich jetzt meine terrasse
sitzen und wahrscheinlich ein gläschen
wein zu übernehmen ist ja schon nach 12
der von der stadt wir haben wir in der
beide kubicki deswegen schenke ich ihnen
auch direkt ein glas ein wir wollen
sozusagen das machen was sie
normalerweise hier auch tun würden in
strande ich schenke 1 wir erinnern uns
herr kubicki es gab eine situation für
den damaligen kanzlerkandidaten peer
steinbrück der sich im wahlkampf
geäußert hat dass eine flasche wein
unter fünf euro das wäre nichts damals
riesen aufregung bei der spd bei ihnen
wäre es wahrscheinlich anders rum oder
bei der fdp will man enttäuscht wenn der
wein zu billig ist nein weil es keine
preisfrage ist ich kann sicher sagen
dass sie auch viele vier euro 30 liter
flasche rein begonnen beispielsweise in
rheinhessen in alzey ich bin mein
kulturpreisträger der stadt alzey in
franken kriegen sie wunderbaren franken
waren unter fünf euro die flasche also
sofern der preis spielt keine rolle denn
geschmacklos es sein und ich habe auch
schon wein kredenzt bekommen 1800 euro
kostet es den concealer hinaus bis
schiffen haben sie dort gemacht oder
sind nett und haben denn sagen wenn ja
wie schmeckt dann kann derjenige der
glaubt er würde eine besondere freude
damit veranlassen denen wir selbst
trinken oder
das hier strand ist der heimatort
gekommen sie gehen sie die kneipe
sprechen sie mit den menschen wie oft
saßen sie ja schon und haben über das
geredet und gelästert was man im
politischen berlin nicht sagen da
regelmäßig wenn ich nach hause komme
hier reden die leute frei die
norddeutschen haben wir ohnehin die
angewohnheit relativ klar zu sprechen
und ihre meinung keinen großen hehl zu
machen und es macht ja auch spaß und man
simeon doch wer nach dem stammtisch
sitzt damit freund zusammen sitzt zu
lästern und auch mal sortieren
loszulassen das wird einfach dazu ist
teil des sozialen bewegungsgefühl ist
neben sich bewegt also hier macht es
einfach viel spaß und hier trägt auch
kann jemand was nach dem man hat ihm
eine vertretung haben wir keine linken
keine grünen wir sind noch ein
ordentlicher ort wir haben eine mehrheit
der union wie ist ein stärker als die
spd trotzdem freut man sich
wechselseitig an das gehört einfach dazu
und dann weiß man macht was für die
gemeinsame sache was sind die größten
themen momentan am stammtisch die sich
auch hier hören wo die leute sagen
mensch das darf ich ja gar nicht mehr
sagen dass das völlig anders was ist das
was ihnen in den kopf kommen also dann
hier bei denen menschen ist die auch
wohn und sich länger kennen dann sagt
man sich alles und läuft auch mal ein
begriff dann über die lippen der in
berlin zu einem riesen schutzschirm für
[ __ ] beispielsweise
zigeunerschnitzel das sind so sachen die
regel richtig keiner drüber auf weil
bisher niemand damit ein beleidigungs
tendenz in folien dann trotzdem die
leute da vorsichtiger geworden aber es
wird momentan sehr viel darüber wie es
weitergehen in unserem land
herausforderung durch die klimakrise
durch strukturwandel kann unser
wohlstand erhalten bleiben muss ich mir
sorgen machen dass wir demnächst
überlaufen werden von flüchtlingen aus
afghanistan und anderswo her der
2015/2016 shop.de gut verarbeitet war
und jetzt in strande hängt der mensch
immer noch den knochen standard mehr als
die bewerber flüchtlinge auf grund
damals das notwendigerweise der fall
gewesen wäre weil die menschen hier auch
eine hohe soziale verantwortung spüren
trotzdem war klar irgendwann sind die
kapazitäten erschöpft bei kindergärten
schulen weil die möglichkeit sich um die
menschen zu kümmern und die furcht
momentan ist sehr groß dass ich das
wiederholen könnte wenn die taliban
tatsächlich in afghanistan ein herrscher
auf richten was im moment ja bestreiten
aber die ersten tendenzen gibt es ja die
furcht millionen menschen kommen wieder
zu uns und wir herrschen dass nicht mehr
die vorstoß relativ weit verbreitet
bevor wir dazu kommen wollen wir zu den
themen wir trinken natürlich ein schluck
zu dem thema herr kubicki aber
vielleicht leute in berlin sagen würden
der worldcom kubicki das ist der
prominenteste alte weiße mann der zugibt
in deutschland wäre das eine beleidigung
für sie wenn ein ball ist ja stimmt ich
bin weiß ich ich bin schon gehört schon
zur älteren generation wurden mir das in
meinem kopf immer noch schwierigkeiten
bereitet damit klar zu kommen und ich
bin männlich und dazu stehe ich auch
allerdings finde ich das ganz
interessant dass diejenigen die dauernd
von diskriminierung sprechen diesen
begriff alter weiß man ja
diskriminierend gebrauchen der soll ja
zur ausgrenzung dienen und nicht dazu
sich zu überlegen ob man nicht den die
ratschläge von alten weisen wenn dann
doch mal beherzigt in vielen
verfassungen der länder haben ältere
menschen eine besondere bedeutung nicht
sie gelten als waise sie gelten als
erfahren und man sollte auch die
ratschläge hören deshalb kann ich mit
dem begriff gut leben aber
diskriminieren lasse ich mich von
jüngeren menschen die das als
ausgrenzung mehr auch nicht haben sie
das gefühl dass alte weiße männer
mittlerweile bisher diskriminiert werden
weil alle sagen mensch die sollen sich
bei der debatte nicht mehr so richtig
dabei sein na ja gemerkt dass man als
alter weißer man sich doch mehr
feminismus kümmern müsste dann ist das
in form der diskriminierung ich hätte
eine sehr interessante diskussion auf
einladung eines groß publikationsorgan
smit einer muslimischen feministin die
mir dann versucht wird zu erklären dass
ich doch als alter weiß man jetzt
abtreten müsste und jüngeren frauen das
feld überlassen soll das politische
spielfeld dass ich mich dafür einsetzen
sollte das jüngere frauen in der politik
was werden könnte und da habe ich ihr
gesagt wissen sie sie machen jetzt genau
das was jedoch brandmarken sie erwarten
von einem mann dass er frauen hilft ich
glaube dass feministin dass frauen sich
durchsetzen aufgrund der qualifikation
fähigkeiten die brauchen meine hilfe
nicht dann jedoch gesagt fragen sie mal
meine eigene frau die braucht meine
hilfe auch nicht früher waren ja männer
wie sie körper sagen fast normal in der
politik so ein bisschen macho jetzt hat
man das gefühl sie sind das bisschen aus
der mode gekommen fühlen sie das auch
nein es liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass
ich mich in aller regel mit der
generation auch um gebe die zu meiner
alten weiter gehört und da kann ich
immer noch sagen finden dass frauen sehr
schön wenn in den koffer trägt und wenn
die tür aufhält und in den mantel hilft
das empfinden sie nicht als
diskriminierung sondern einfach nur als
höflichkeit und das werde ich mich auch
nicht mehr abgewöhnen ich bin zu alt um
die noch zu ändern ich will das auch
nicht und wir machen mal das richtige
kompliment aus ihrer sicht einer frau
zunächst einmal indem man sie anlächelt
denn visualisierung ist das a und o man
merkt sofort ob jemand erst böse mit
allen meint oder auch nicht diese
menschenkenntnis haben die meisten
menschen intuitiv erlernt in ihrem leben
komplett wir wollen zum ersten
themenkomplex kommen über den ich mit
ihnen sprechen will das thema wo können
sie wog definieren wenn ich höre denke
ich mal lockt also es ist es instrument
mit dem man wunderbar kochen kann dabei
wog ist offensichtlich eine bewegung die
glaubt dass wir durch sprachliche
diskriminierung gesellschaftlichen
fortschritt herbeiführen können wir
wollen uns das einmal anschauen
ich erkläre es ihnen doch was heißt das
eigentlich
aufgeweckt wer vogue ist kapiert alle
missstände der welt wer bock ist kennt
alle lösungen gegen rassismus und
diskriminierung der burg ist hat das
perfekte vokabular und macht es ein
recht nah liebe zuschauer innen ich kann
mir vorstellen dass es sich für unsere
kanzlerkandidat innen so ein bisschen
anfühlen muss wie vor weihnachten ich
finde viele sachen nicht in ordnung
wenn jemand so hier an ihrem stammtisch
von ihren freunden plötzlich anfängt zu
reden was würden sie denn sagen
wie bei uns würde niemand so anfangen zu
reden aber wenn er so reden würde würden
wir uns erstmal die frage stellt
verstehen wir ihnen wissen wir was am
main sprach ist ein kommunikationsmittel
und dann würden wir so akzeptiert jeder
soll so reden wie er glaubt dass es
richtig ist man bei manchen das gefühl
wenn ich das im fernsehen sehe ist eine
sprachstörung aber daran kann ich mich
gewöhnen wie gesagt nein er ist nicht
vorgeschrieben wird dass ich so reden
mussten sie jetzt bahn haben sie freunde
die länder
ich habe freunde
ob sie denn dann weiß ich nicht weiß was
trauen sich das vielleicht von ihnen ein
quatsch es verlieren sehen dass wenn sie
herum gehen dann werden sie erleben dass
die menschen bei der ansprache
vielleicht auch mal
sehr geehrte damen und herren sagen oder
auch den weiblichen part mit sprechen
aber das hier ich jemanden getroffen
habe der mann von kandidatinnen spricht
oder von taliban innen ist mir noch
nicht passiert oder islamisten was
tatsächlich passiert ist im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk wie sehr hat sich
da die sprache von dem entfernt was sie
in ihrem wahlkreis hier strand erleben
wir wohnen ja hier auf dem land wo wir
auch bestellt orientiert sind
wir müssen akzeptieren dass 86 prozent
der menschen die diese form der
staatlichen verschönerung nicht
akzeptieren und ich wollen
kann man daran arbeiten und werden dass
es vielleicht mehr werden die sich so
verhalten wollen aber man sollte die
menschen nicht versuchen zu zwingen sich
anders zu artikulieren als ich es
gewohnt und als sie es wollen und man
sollte vor allen dingen nicht jeweils
einmal dafür keine mehrheit hat das zum
offiziellen sprachgebrauch erheben
erkennen damit dass strafe bald geben
könnte wenn nicht geändert das halte ich
für ausgeschlossen weil es richtig und
verfassungswidrig wäre
es gab ja sowie ansätze bei hochschulen
dabei schulen wo arbeiten die mich
länder gerecht geschrieben worden sind
anders bewertet worden sind das
dankenswerterweise von der
rechtsprechung gekippt worden noch
einmal ich warne dringend davor zu
glauben dann könnte durch diese form der
sprache die neugestaltung menschen
menschen erziehen es gibt diskussionen
auch hier in schleswig-holstein da sind
universität zum beispiel das ländern
verboten werden soll ist das das
richtige müsste das noch ausgedehnt
werden dass man eben insbesondere
schulen universitäten also staatliche
einrichtungen dafür sorgt dass das
gender nicht stattfindet wir verbieten
würde ich nicht allerdings würde ich
dafür sorge tragen wollen dass die
deutsche sprache vernünftig erlernt
werden kann gender bedeutet ja auch eine
barriere für die ihnen die deutschen
lernen wollen und wenn wir leichte
sprache wollen müssen wir sie nicht
verkomplizieren ich wäre dafür dass wir
uns darauf verständigen dass jedenfalls
in der schule wo deutsch gelehrt wird
man sich an die amerikanische
vernünftigen den ordentlichen und auch
leicht zu erlernenden regeln hält und
ich versuche neues
werk zu setzen ich kann mich erinnern
ich habe sozusagen landtag von schleswig
holstein weil eine rede gehalten und die
sternchen mit gesprochen ist immer sehr
schön wenn sie also eigentlich
liebe freund sternchen ihnen da haben
selbst meine grünen partner dann erklärt
nach 360 soll damit aufhören weil das
eine verballhornung sei ich habe seit
gemeint ist doch ernst wenn es ernst
meint muss sie erst noch mit lesen sonst
versteht ja keiner dass ich tatsächlich
dann auch also für eine grüne sich von
industrie ja bei sternchen schon deshalb
haben sie jetzt dieses innen eingeführt
und der streichung helfen ja auch nicht
weiter das kann man auch nicht mitlesen
also wird es bei den kindern ist es
relativ komisch aber noch einmal wenn
menschen glauben sie sollten zu reden
ist mir egal solange ich verstehe es
wenn ich weiß was sie meinen ist mir
sicher schalten sie um im tv wenn jemand
anfängt zu ändern nein ich finde es wie
gesagt teilweise nur sprach störend
stellt man sprach empfinden aber noch
einmal ist er wirklich keine seine
vision wir wollen zu einem weiteren
heiß diskutierten thema kubicki das
thema klima das thema umwelt
und kommen hier zum seo wie fahren das
ist das modell was wir hier mitgebracht
haben
wie wissen sie können ja auch den sound
vision es so wenig anhört war saßen sie
da schon mal drin so warte da saß ich
auch schon mal drin ich glaube auch weil
sie den helm foren hatten als sich im
irak unterwegs war da war das fahrzeug
aber vor allem gepanzert können sie sich
vorstellen so was selbst zu fahren oder
wäre das für sie nichts
ich bin schon bei uns so gegen den
garten tor
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich mit dem um die
ecke kommen würde
also
da müssen schon ordentlich zwei kinder
sowie bei der passen auch zwei kinder so
zu sein ich finde viele sachen nicht
er würde auch was wären sie bereit zu
verzichten damit dass mehr so schön
bleibt hinter hin
dass sevilla die überlegung dass wenn
ich verzichte das märchen bleibt und das
halte ich für
etwas ja geholt ich glaube nicht dass
wir das klima retten indem wir
verzichten sondern indem wir uns
gedanken machen insgesamt wenig
technologischen entwicklungen wie ein
gang setzen können und tatsächlich
kinderschutz betreuen zu können beispiel
sgb ii nicht er ist wie spielt keine
rolle es sei denn man hat immer zwei
versionen dort und es wird wie der
elektromobilität betrieben wird der
wasserstoff betrieben wird gehen sollen
der störung außer man ist gegen große
fahrzeuge tempolimit genau das gleiche
wenn ich nicht emittierende kraftstoffe
habe dann spielt das keine rolle ist
nicht zum klimaschutz das ist dann
völlig wurst
sowie fahren hier kann so weiterleben
wie er will ja solange jetzt darüber
gedanken macht wie er dazu beitragen
kann den es den co2 fußabdruck etwas zu
vermindern aber ich würde aber wieder
lernen oder eindeutig ja ich würde mir
jetzt überlegen ob ich noch habe ich
noch ein termin im aussage und ihnen
verbrennen muss haben ja nein habe ich
nicht
nicht ausgeräumten weißen ich wollte
sondern weil schlicht und ergreifend in
mein neues niveau nicht optisch
angepasst der optisch gepasst hätten
zugenommen ja ich hatte man wenn man
haus davor über 30 jahre einen kamin
bedauerlicherweise habe die ein oder
zweimal im januar an gemacht aber er sah
einfach immer gut aus die idee man
könnte jetzt kuschelige wärme herstellt
optisch auch ist das ein ganz vernünftig
ist man in einer berliner wohnung habe
ich jetzt eine eine optische täuschung
der elektrischen kamin sitzen nämlich
optisch täuscht aber
mit solchen petitessen werden wir das
klima im zweifel nicht retten sondern
wir müssen uns die wirklich die frage
stellen welche großen technologische
entwicklungen können wir ins werk setzen
umziehen und zwar im großen maßstab zu
ersetzen wir sind schlecht wie holstein
geben wir haben hier relativ viel
windstrom dann abgeleitet werden können
wir mittlerweile ein wasserstoff
kompetenzzentrum
es gibt unternehmen wie beispielsweise
basf die hofreporter sun in park in die
nordsee packen wollen um strom an land
im wasserstoff umzuwandeln den sie
brauchen für ihre prozesse wo sie
momentan noch noch da brennen das müssen
wir schnellstmöglich umsetzen dafür
brauchen wir keine öffentlichen mittel
die wollen dass privat finanzieren bauen
schnelle verfahren wie oft haben sie
hier schon am stammtisch über kreta
gelästert mit ihren vor ich selbst noch
die ihre andere schon weil wir menschen
methoden lebensalter sagen ist immer
schön wenn es eine 17-jährige sagen
sollen wie die welt funktioniert
was sagen sie dann
17 jährige wir waren ja auch mal jung
nicht auf 17 jährige können genial und
glorreiche ideen haben aber etwas mehr
lebenserfahrung dass prozesse auf zeit
brauchen dass menschen auch
lernerfahrungen machen müssen dass man
menschen nicht zwingen kannst du etwas
was sie nicht einsehen wäre schon
hilfreich also der hai konkrete hat uns
nicht wesentlich weiter gebracht außer
einige kids auf die straße aber auch da
sage ich wer glaubt das falstaff lucia
die jugend sei der ist nicht von dieser
welt das ist eine eine kleine elitäre
schicht von leuten die aus
akademikerhaushalten kommen oder aus
reichen haushalten kommen dass es nicht
die jugend in deutschland aber ist das
wirklich so wenn man die anschaut dass
der großteil der jugend die große
mehrheit am ende bei dieser
bundestagswahl für die grünen stimmen
wird und oder stimmt würde auch wenn man
sich die jüngeren anschaut die nicht
berechtigt sind dh offenbar haben die
grünen das was richtig gemacht die er in
kombination mit freies for future
häufiger auftreten ja sie gelten wurden
sie gelten als 70 vermittelt einen
lebenssinn nachdem die meisten menschen
der christliche glauben macht mal
gekommen ist wollen menschen hier hat
irgendwas sinnvollen beitragen aber es
stimmt mich hoffnungsfroh dass die
freien demokraten am platz zwei liegen
bei den unter 18 jährigen
das zeigt ja auch dass auch dort
vernunft langsam aber sicher an geld
findet dass unsere überlegung die welt
digitaler zu machen als es eigentlich
ist und damit auch wieder zu machen auch
die jungen menschen erreicht ich glaube
wenn man argumentiert und nicht nur
polemisiert kann man sehr sehr viele
junge menschen erreichen auch aus ihrem
leben was du noch etwas zu wollen
leistung zu bringen die probleme nicht
als angst zu empfinden sondern als
herausforderung sieht zu bewältigen darf
man heute noch sagen mir ist klimaschutz
egal
natürlich darf man das sagen aber das
sind wahnsinnige position weil wir alle
davon betroffen sind ob es uns gelingt
in absehbarer zeit die co2 emissionen zu
reduzieren was sie sind doch eher
genervt von oder dass sie sagen was soll
dieser hype und kann ich bin genervt
davon dass menschen glauben konnte sich
auf die erde geschickt die welt zu
retten und dann gäbe es keine
demokratien keine rechtsstaaten ich hab
das robert habeck mal geschrieben robert
wenn du glaubst es gebe nur einen weg
die welt zu retten dann musst du
demokratie und rechtsstaat abschaffen
dann darf man nicht mehr klagen gegen
maßnahmen die der weltrettung dienen vor
allem darf man sich nicht anders
entscheiden wir da nie anders wählen
natürlich die grünen müssten jetzt ja
verzweifeln wenn 15% sie wählen dann
müssen sie etwas falsch gemacht haben
bei der agenda klimaschutz ich glaube
schon wir haben schließlich schon das
problem dass jetzt unser windkraftausbau
wieder torpediert wird durch klagen beim
ovg in regionalplanung also wir müssen
uns irgendwann mal entscheiden ob wir
das ist robert habe geantwortet auf
ihren nichts weil darauf ja auch
schlechterdings nicht antworten können
wahrscheinlich denkt darüber nach hat ja
ohnehin die rhetorisch
herausragend gute angewohnheit probleme
immer in frageform zu klein können
während ich frage mich können wir noch
so weiterleben ich frage mich wissen was
der verein nicht ändern ich habe ihm ich
frage mich wäre er schon nach der
dritten frage habe ich ihn gefragt was
antwortest du dir ich frage mich warum
butterweck werde am ende kanzler
geworden
ich muss mich jetzt in die pedale
symmetrie der grünen nicht einmischen
aber wenn man sieht wie seine
performance war außerhalb des grünen
milieus dann glaube ich schon hätte er
mehr menschen für die grünen begeistert
als er das getan hat und ohne dass ich
jetzt nahe treten will
aber wie gesagt wenn sie aufhören meint
aus meiner aus meiner sicht das sag ich
jetzt mal ist freier demokrat im
wahlkampf das ist aus meiner sicht ein
glück dass robert nicht nicht der
kanzlerkandidat der grünen ist freundin
sie mit ihm lieber korrelieren als mann
olaf scholz
ich kann sagen robert habe und ich haben
gemeinsam mit deinem günther 2017 in
schleswig holstein ein koalitionsvertrag
ausgehandelt in vergleichsweise kurzer
zeit die koalition trägt bis heute wir
haben auch konflikte aber wir werden
ordentlich erledigt das ist die
beliebteste regierungsvertreter stand
seit bestehen des landes es funktioniert
also
und ich kann mit robert habe persönlich
haben sicherheit besser als mit olaf
scholz der ist mir einfach zu dröge
zu dröge aber sehr wahrscheinlich wird
ist oder das wissen wir nicht die
wahrscheinlichkeit jedenfalls ist
momentan größer als die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es nicht wird
aber gewählt wird am 26 september dann
haben wir ergebnisse kann damit etwas
drin
als ein platz armin laschet persönlich
wird schwer die tatsache dass das gerade
die csu bis gestern noch knüppel
zwischen die geschmissen hat ist für die
union eine katastrophe ein solches maß
an mobilität wie von söder oder blumen
habe ich wirklich in meinem politischen
leben ich bin 50 jahren ist dabei noch
nicht erlebt also wenn asche sagt selbst
der zweite hätte eine chance mehr dem
deutschen bundestag zu leben und haben
sie in derselben sekunde sagen markus
söder nein entweder nummer eins der
opposition ist das eben keine
unterstützung des kandidaten seien also
sie müssen sich sie müssen sich schon
wir sind auf olaf scholz einstellen ich
stelle mich nach wie vor darauf ein dass
jamaika möglich ist und wir werden alles
versuchen dass auch ins werk zu setzen
wie gesagt wir stehen schon eine
wunderbare blaupause dass damit wirklich
gute politik gemacht werden kann auch
wenn berlin das andere falls ein land
aber
wir sind auf alles vorbereitet die
freien demokraten nicht das einzige was
wir sagen viele menschen können sich
darauf verlassen dass die zusagen die
wir in dem auch eingehalten werden sind
niemand sollte uns zu gesprächen
einladen damit uns über steuererhöhungen
reden geht es gibt ja häufig das
vorurteil oder auch den vorwurf dass
insbesondere vermögende die fdp wählen
dass sie die partei der besserverdiener
sind wir wollen einmal über das thema
reichtum sprechen
es aber wissen sie ungefähr wurde
benzinpreise sind nicht ganz konkret
immer wo die benzinpreise sind weil ich
ja nicht jeden tag drauf gucke und ich
habe ja auch ein ganz ordentliches
einkommen deshalb bücher nicht zu den
leuten die jetzt immer auf den letzten
die also ganz genau bei jedem preis
hingucken also da könnte ich ihnen auch
nicht viele preise konkret sagen wie man
ich finde viele sachen nicht den
benzinpreis denkt das ist bei
verschiedenen tankstellen
unterschiedlicher größenordnung ein euro
70 momentan ein euro 75
tendenz weiter steigend muss man das als
politiker wissen eigentlich nicht also
meine frau sagt immer wieder ich danke
meinen mit der karte und wir können sie
ja sogar ziemlich benzinpreis ist aber
man merkt schon am ende des tages
investoren geworden ist dann versucht
man seinen sein fahrverhalten euro
würden sie persönlich sich als reich
bezeichnet
ja ich bin reich an lebensfreude und ich
es gibt mit sicherheit
100000 menschen die deutlich mehr mehr
einkommen haben als ich und die deutlich
vermögen da sind als ich aber das was
ich ja gereicht mir meine mutter hat
immer gesagt nicht der liebe gott hat
keine taschen und du kannst nichts
mitnehmen so fern wenn ich mich am leben
erfreuen kann wenn ich mir mein wein
leisten kann wenn ich mit meinem freund
zusammen sein kann dann ist das mehr als
alle seine ab was ist man reich in
deutschland was muss auf dem konto
stehen
naja also man ist schon wann ist schon
aus ihrer sicht nicht aus der
allgemeinen befindet wenn ich denn ich
mir alles das kaufen kann was ich mir
vorstelle ohne ohne abzudrehen ich muss
gar keine 80 fuß gehabt haben mehr
reichen auch 30 was haben sie da ein
neues boot gekauft ja so ist aber wir
mal an der küste wohnt und keine mutter
dann ist meine arme tropf jetzt eine
menge leute die deutlich weniger
verdienen als ich und trotzdem mein
bruder macht daran freuen weil das ein
teil ihrer lebensfreude ist und dann
muss man das auch akzeptieren so macht
sie stolz wenn sie auf ihr eigenes konto
schauen
main konnte sie deutlich schlechter aus
das ist konnte meiner frau dass sie
wirklich mal sagen das macht mich stolz
dass wie konnte das passiert ist macht
es macht mich stolz dass mein haus jetzt
nach über 30 jahren abbezahlt ist dass
das tatsächlich eigentum ist es macht
mich stolz dass ich ihren diesen
wunderbaren ort leben können das könnte
ich mir heute wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mehr leisten vor 35 jahren war es nicht
ganz unproblematisch aber die preise
genau so explodiert hinein die anderen
exponierten es zeigt aber auch wie
relativ das ist mit dem reicht es kann
genauso schnell zu ende sein es gibt
orte da sind bundeswehrsoldaten
abgezogen urplötzlich 150 jahren
familienhaus zur verfügung stellt ist
das nichts mehr wert also man muss schon
aufpassen erreichte uns etwas
stichtagsbezogen ist aber vermögen etwas
was erst dann einen wert hat wenn's
liquidiert wird wenn ich kann kein
quadratmeter boden aus meinem wunsch der
ausstellung ist im finanz anzugehen wenn
ich grundsteuer zahlen muss untersagt
steuer zahlen und oder vermögenssteuer
zahlen sie wurden als kind eines
angestellten in braunschweig geboren wie
viel bedeutet ihnen das dass sie diese
karriere hingelegt haben
das bedeutet mir sehr viel ich bin der
erste in meiner familie akademiker ist
mir ist nichts geschenkt funktion zu
hause alles was ich hab ich mir habe ich
mir erarbeitet das heiligste schicksal
scheint interessanterweise mit drei
stehen beispielsweise oder mit gerhard
schröder oder auch nicht der stein oder
sigmar gabriels interessant wie so
karrieren verlaufen sind ist denn nun
mit unterschieden parteien gelandet aber
es macht mich schon stolz dass ich
meinen kindern eine gute ausbildung habe
finanzieren können das aus dem
vernünftige menschen geworden sind dass
sie glücklich aufwachsen konnten dass
sie keine angst haben müssen für die
zukunft das macht mich stolz tatsächlich
und
das erlaubt mir auch mehr in aller ruhe
und gelassenheit das war ein gläschen
wein zu sitzen und mein leben revue
passieren zu lassen jetzt haben sie mal
gesagt wenn sie zurückgehen würden nach
berlin dann würden sie zum trinker und
hohen bock das war 2012 da hab ich
erstmal 2010 2010
was ist daraus geworden
ja zunächst einmal bin ich täglich und
moralisch gefestigt mittlerweile und wie
schafft man das ja in dem man wenig
berlin bin konzentriere mich auf meine
heutige arbeit die mich tatsächlich in
berlin eine sitzungswochen von 7 uhr bis
23 uhr geschäft noch in berlin ist ja
verlockend da sind die basis immer offen
ja nun haben wir zwei jahre corona
halbjahr corona da war nichts mehr auch
unabhängig davon wenn sich um 23 uhr mit
ihrem job dann wollen sie nach hause das
ist das alter glaube ich auch ich bin
auch nicht mehr ganz so schnell also
also wer gefährlicher für sie geworden
wenn sie als jüngerer mann nach berlin
gegangen werden als politiker ja nicht
nur in berlin also vor 40 jahren wäre
das leben überall für mich gefährlich
gewesen als gegenwärtig weil ich wie
gesagt ein sehr lebensfroher mensch mit
aber sie haben ja mal fast davor bewahre
hand nach berlin zu gehen das wäre
nichts für mich da dieser alltag als
abgeordneter wenn sie das jetzt von
innen betrachten nur noch als jemand der
in der politik sozusagen der bin in der
politik noch wichtiger geworden ist was
hat sie daran noch an und wo sagen will
ich da lag ich falsch mich ekelt mich an
dem politik überhaupt nichts dran ich
stellte fest dass der stressfaktor
nochmal gestiegen ist exorbitant
schwierig ist die wie gesagt stehen
dauernd unter öffentlicher beobachtung
von ihnen wir dauernd leistung ärgerte
sie können sich keine schwäche leisten
und gerade bei ihren abgeordneten ist
das so dass sie auch im wettbewerb
stehen zu allen anderen für den platz
auf der liste für einen möglichen
potenziellen nachfolger im wahlkreis und
dieser stress den müssen sie irgendwann
abbauen wenn sie niemanden um sich herum
haben indem sie wirklich vertrauen kann
mit dem sie reden können da gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten nicht sie gehen nach innen
hat katja suding gerade beschrieben
warum sie den betrieb jetzt entflohen
ist mein ziel unter gekostet hat oder
sie flüchten in alle möglichen formen
von drogen betrogen man sich nicht nur
rate drohungen nicht nur alkohol sondern
eine andere beziehung auf das ist eine
droge dass sie dann streicheleinheiten
brauchen und das ist an dem
politikbetrieb in berlin nach wie vor
gefährlich sehen sie für diesen
bereichen von denen das passiert ist
also ohne jetzt namen zu nennen dabei
sind das großes problem in der in der
berliner bar jeder jede fraktion hat
einen beauftragten der sich und
kolleginnen kollegen kümmert die genau
vor diesem problem stehen stehen
entweder in einen kompletten bernaus zu
verfallen oder aber abzudriften und das
ist ganz gut so dass man sich um die
kollegen kollegen auch conti muss auch
fraktionsübergreifend was ich auch sehr
gut finde nicht dass man dass man sich
auch im kolleginnen kollegen aus anderen
fraktionen kümmert man merkt da läuft
gerade was schief
wenn sie jetzt sehen denn den nächsten
monaten wird sich entscheiden wer
deutschland regiert ist selbstbewusst
die nächsten monate weil er die
koalitionsgespräche wahrscheinlich
dauernd werden warum wollen sie nicht
minister werden liegt das daran dass sie
auch weiterhin arbeiten wollen geld wird
ihn nur nein ich habe in meinem leben
außerdem geld verdient ich schleiche
mich gerade aus meiner kanzlei
vollständig aus ich werde nächstes jahr
70 und es
schuldig auch meinen mandanten die eine
volle leistungsfähigkeit von wir
brauchen und nicht nur weite welt
behandelt werden müssen ich arbeite
meine mandate hab ich nehme keine neuen
mehr an und das wird im nächsten jahr
beendet sein dann ist es auch gut so was
man sollte schon feststellen dass man
nicht so lange arbeiten soll dieses mal
ausgetragen wurde wohl mir das richtig
viel spaß macht und es wird auch meine
letzte legislaturperiode sein in der ich
politisch tätig bin warum dann sagen
mensch präsident da sagt jetzt ich will
finanzminister wird das finde ich auch
das finde ich auch sehr gut
es gibt den irrglauben dass man erst
dann etwas wir wollen es der politiker
wenn man minister geworden ist ich kann
ihnen sicher sagen schauen sie dass
schleswig-holstein ich bin ja nicht
minister geworden obwohl ich hätte
werden können mehrfach ich war lange
zeit fraktionsvorsitzender jetzt auch
eine regierungstragende fraktion ist und
nichts es gibt nichts wichtigeres sie ja
wesentlich größere freiheitsgrade sie
können wesentlich offener reden sind
nirgendwo angeboten das hat spaß gemacht
und sie reizen in berlin
nicht unbedingt aber dass wir etwas dem
ich mir gehen würde wenn christian
lindner ins kabinett geht und sagt wir
brauchen
jemanden der diese fraktion zusammen
hält mit natürlicher autorität würde ich
darüber nachdenken ist nicht das was ich
anstrebe ich würde gerne vizepräsident
des deutschen bundestages bleiben ein
richtig toller job was ist mit
bundespräsident damit ja auch gerade
drüber gesprochen und grünen bekommen
oder vielleicht kann man sie damit ja
auch noch das ist das schöne ist dass
wir das hier nicht am tisch verteilen
wer was wird sondern sie sind wir am
stammtisch sozusagen sie braucht immer
noch mehrheit in der bundesversammlung
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die
freidemokraten an dem mehrheit
organisieren könnten um einen
bundespräsidenten ins werk zu setzen die
halte ich für eher unwahrscheinlich und
ich finde wirklich dass frank waldmann
frank walter steinmeier das ist richtig
gut machen das auch bleiben soll ich
mich vor zwei jahren schon so geäußert
und daran mitzuwirken
auch eine meiner aufgaben seien im
deutschen bundestag wenn sie sagen das
wird das sein woran sie arbeiten wenn
wir uns jetzt anschauen wir sitzen jetzt
hier zusammen beim weinen wie muss man
sich das vorstellen wie oft haben sie
schon jemanden von der spd getroffen von
der cdu oder darüber irgendwie gepokert
wird menschen wie machen wir das nach
der wahl wie läuft das ab
jetzt soll ich ja aus dem nähkästchen
plaudern man macht das so es gibt
logischerweise auch vor der wahl immer
wenn man sich trifft ein leichtes
abtasten also erstmal stellt man fest
kann man mit jemandem offen reden ja
oder nein und wie offen sie will reden
wir das gegen einen verwendet wie das
missbrauchte das öffentliche hin und her
ist man noch so fallen und versucht mal
und sagt im wasser und versucht
herauszufinden ob das wieder
zurückkommen man legt keine fallen aber
man merkt sehr schnell ob gespräche
jemand gehört das lied den charakter des
vertraulichen beiden oder nicht
vertraulich sind und wie man merkt sie
bleiben nicht vertraulich macht es
keinen sinn das weiter zu machen wir
treffen uns regelmäßig im deutschen
bundestag am ball veranstaltet man das
regelmäßig auch nach beet live wenn ich
da bin noch auf ein gläschen wein
zusammen und dann gibt es ein leichtes
abtasten und das ist einfach so wann
sondierten nicht sondern man versucht
einen finden zu finden ein gefühl dafür
zu empfinden ob sie sich wirklich
intensive gespräche lohnt ja oder nein
und die werden dann tatsächlich erst
geführt wenn die wahl entschieden ist
aber ich kann ehrlich kann ich kann pd
und fdp und cdu ich kann ihnen sagen
dass ich mit einem kollegen kollegen aus
allen fraktionen des deutschen
bundestages wirklich persönlich gute
kontakte habe das betrifft weil den
grünen britta haßelmann die
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin frau
brannte das betrifft robert habeck
sowieso ich habe kontakt zu den
sozialdemokraten das betrifft den
kollegen hat man den kollegen rathaus
enden den mann mit den besten er stimmen
ergebnisse für die spd bei der union bin
ich freundschaftlich verbunden mit den
kollegen große brömer den ersten pdf
also das findet sich in wieder auch hier
oft sagen die den mensch wolfgang
kubicki was etwas was hast du da schon
wieder raus gehauen ansprüchen
manche machen das anerkennt manche sagen
hat muss das so sein und dann sage ich
mache ja es musste wohl so sein aber das
hat zu den guten persönlichen
beziehungen bisher noch keinen schaden
angerichtet was war für sie die debatte
die sie persönlich
hinterher am meisten
ja
wo sie sich geärgert haben
ich ärgere mich regelmäßig verdi button
bei vielen debatten angestoßen habe man
die meinungsfreiheit debatte ich ärgere
mich darüber dass das war aufgenommen
worden ist auch von großen publikationen
zwar gartenzeit spiegelbild ja ohnehin
wir haben ein demokratieproblem wenn
zwei drittel der menschen glauben sie
könnten ihre meinung nicht mehr frei
äußern das bundesverfassungsgerichts
seien regelmäßig die meinungsfreiheit
ist eine der tragenden säulen eines
demokratischen gemeinwesens und darüber
müssen wir als politische
entscheidungsträger uns wirklich
gedanken machen wie empfinden wir
bekommen ja auch nicht mehr mit richtig
mit was in der bevölkerung passiert wenn
menschen das gefühl dann ich äußere mich
einfach nicht mehr das hilft gerade
schon erzählt wenn sie hier am
stammtisch sitzen zum beispiel in
strande und in der in der kneipe wo sie
die leute schon lange kennen was wird
dann noch angesprochen was den leuten
wichtig ist wir gerade gehört
zigeunerschnitzel
flüchtlinge was sind die themen der wird
sie unterstützen sind das zentrale
welche macht keiner sozusagen eine
schere im kopf wenn er sich sprachlich
äußert weil alle die mit ihm zusammen
sind nicht das gefühl haben das wird
jetzt gegen sie verwendet das problem
ist ja die angst der menschen wenn sie
sich äußern einen falschen satz einfach
mal raus hauen wird er so massiv gegen
sie verwendet dass ihre existenzielle
probleme bekommen können haben sie das
beispiel
[Musik]
also beispielweise kleben ist tönnies
als auf einer veranstaltung sagte also
ich mach das jetzt mal nicht mit seinen
worten so man mit den richtigen worten
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass die
bevölkerungsentwicklung eingehen wird
weil wir uns sonst alle überlegungen den
klimaschutz sparen können und was
entwicklung dämpfen
wenn man dadurch ein dass die menschen
besser geht das strom haben dass die
wohlstand haben wir können das
statistisch nachweisen die besser ist
menschen einer gesellschaft desto
weniger kinder entwicklungen sie wenn
wir dieses problem in den griff bekommen
2,5 milliarden menschen mehr die
nächsten jahrzehnte
dann können wir uns die frage wie
bewerten die klimawandel lineare schon
wieder dinge brauchen alle wohnungen in
beschäftigungen namen usw insofern hängt
das mit ihnen zusammen in uns etwas das
gerade der kowisa reitzle auf der
fdp-parteitag am sonntag gesagt hat
nicht wir müssen klimaschutz und gefällt
muss man doch miteinander denken aber
was bedeutet dass dann wir müssen jetzt
zum beispiel in china dürfen die
menschen nur noch zwei kinder bekommen
damit sie davon sind die chinesen wieder
weg weil sie festgestellt haben dass
ihre demokratische entwicklung dann ein
riesenproblem wartet weil irgendwann
nicht mehr genug junge menschen da sind
um die eltern zu versorgen er hat das
bedeutet dass wir einen wesentlich
beitrag dafür leisten müssen dass es in
vier regionen der erde den menschen
besser geht und deshalb sage ich noch
mal die überlegung von unseren grünen
und freien flug freund nicht wir
predigen jetzt verzicht wird in afrika
oder in asien auf großes gehör treffen
das ist eine illusion
die menschen wollen selbstständig besser
leben also müssen wir als vor
industrienationen dazu beitragen
klimaschutz und wirtschaftlicher zu
verbinden denn sonst wird es noch mal
folgen das ist eine person was sind noch
klartext themen die sie in hier in der
im restaurant oder in der bar in der
kneipe in strande wahrnehmen die zu
wenig eine rolle spielte war kann
die kasse an dass die meisten menschen
das gefühl dass durch für 100 pandemie
maßnahmen sie über gebühren in ihren
grund und freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt
worden sind wir leben hier in strande
also hier anzuordnen dass sie bei vier
windstärken masken auf dem deich tragen
müssen gucken sich die leute an die er
ja segler sind sagen das ist so wieder
gut bei william tell macht gar keinen
sinn
es gibt dazu auch wir hatten hier in
strategien jedem ort den ich gerne ganz
prohibition scanner also knallten die
trotzdem geöffnet hatten obwohl es
verboten werden sie mal reingeschaut
selbstverständlich was denn sonst wir
haben hier keinen einzigen fall in
strande mich also passieren dass ein
paar illegal gerodet partys teilgenommen
er hat nämlich corona park ist und dann
es haben sich leute schlicht und
ergreifend auch an den stammtischen
getroffen obwohl es verboten weil sie
weil sie gesagt haben hier ist nicht sie
ist keine wir haben rotz potts in kiel
in gaarden und mettenhof schick sie hat
nicht einen einzigen fall gehabt wir
nehmen also was wird dann gewesen
menschen muss ich gestehen wir das war
das ist wohl vom computer jeder kennt
ihn was wäre denn wenn der dorfpolizist
land gelaufen wäre und gesagt hätte
mensch der sitz der kombi genau an der
dorfaue mit getrieben an die arbeit
selbstverständlich weil die leute sagen
wir befolgen das was sinnvoll ist dass
er nachvollziehen können aber unsinnige
maßnahmen nicht wir haben ja stand auch
die erklärung wir hatten niemals darf
mehr als eine etwa so was einem anderen
haushalt empfangen und gleichzeitig weil
es ja alle wollten bundesweit waren wir
gesagt das wird nicht kontrolliert wie
ein wein ist das ein ehepaar mit dem sie
lange bevor jetzt etwas gegenüber wohnt
zu trennen zwei stunden manchmal stand
die ehefrau die hat kein mensch hat sich
daran gehalten ist wahrscheinlich habe
ich die paare auch weiter getroffen wie
vorher aus und haben sie keine sorge
dass da irgend jemand vorbeikommt ein
foto macht und das online stellt und
sagt irgendwie mensch da sitzt jetzt der
kubicki in der kneipe das darf man doch
gar nicht dass das verboten wie gut der
die ein foto machen können der wert gar
nicht reingekommen ist freundlich zu
formulieren und wenn jemand fotografiert
von von meinem nachbarn kubicki trifft
sich mit einem weiteren pärchen die
gegner gut einsammeln 250 euro bußgeld
aber es hat eben nicht nie davon
abgehalten meine nachbarn zu trennen
oder meine freunde zu trennen bevor der
braten wir nie davon abgehalten meine
kinder zu trennen wenn sie mich besucht
das heißt sie sind den regeln ist wahr
dass die virus völlig egal ist die
beiden leben zu sagen wir leben zusammen
auch wenn wir uns getrennt hätten wäre
es wenn es denn da gewesen völlig egal
also diese unsinnigen maßnahmen davon
gab es eine reihe die haben dazu geführt
dass auch sehr viel verdruss zerstört
und es hätte man sich das besser
überlegt und nicht nicht versucht zu
dokumentieren dass der staat die macht
hat im 2 sowas anzuordnen ohne es
durchsetzen zu können dann wäre glaube
ich eine viel grössere zustimmung
außerdem pandemie maßnahmen erfolgt also
der fall gewesen das heißt sie haben die
maßnahmen in der mpk nicht nur
kritisiert sondern sie sind denn bewusst
entgegen getreten ich habe von meinem
recht auf auch so nobis handeln gebrauch
gemacht wir wollten das einmal anschauen
was die menschen über corona zu sagen
[Musik]
ich finde viele sachen nicht in ordnung
und natürlich halte ich mich an die
gesetze die dann geschlossen werden das
ist selbstverständlich für mich aber ich
darf selber sagen ich fühle mich in
vielen sachen meiner freiheitsrechte
beraubt das kann ich sagen ich bin eine
ältere bürgerinnen dieses landes ich
habe diese regierung gewählt und ich bin
eigentlich entschuldigen sie bitte sehr
enttäuscht mit strengeren masken pflicht
das hat man ja schon mal vor 14 tagen
hier in der innenstadt und daran gewohnt
mutig und gesundheit steht heute über
allen dingen der kubicki also wir haben
gelernt sie waren weiter in den dorfkern
hier oder den stadtkeller wie man es
nennt werden wenn sie jetzt sich das
anschauen dass die regeln ja immer noch
weitergehen es gibt masten schlecht es
gibt immer noch kein ende in sicht es
gibt weiterhin beschränkung
wann hat das ein ende
es könnte eigentlich schon zu ende sein
weil ja das infektionsschutzgesetz davon
ausgeht den grundlegenden maßnahmen
treffen wir um eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern die
steht gar nicht mehr im raum
und es hat ja in den letzten monaten
immer wieder neue erklärung gegeben
warum die maßnahme ich aufgelöst werden
können ernst waren es die älteren die
sind alle bis zu 90 prozent geimpft da
kann nicht mehr viel passieren
dann war es die möglichkeit dass nicht
alle entweder geburt bekommen hatten das
haben sie mittlerweile auch die ihr
leben hat ja bis juli noch erklärt wenn
alle an dem angebot bekommen haben also
alle erwachsenen dann gibt es keine
rechtliche grundlage mehr für die
aufrechterhaltung der maßnahmen jetzt
auch wieder verschoben worden und so
dänische frauen dann ganz anders
reagiert sie haben alle maßnahmen
aufgelöst nachdem klar war alle über 60
jährigen sind ordentlich geimpft worden
für den rest ist es unproblematisch 100
system und das tun wir alles wieder
öffnen
ich glaube das wird nicht mehr sehr
lange dauern weil nicht nur die
insolvenzzahlen sie wir sind ja hier
sind ja nicht einmal vier bälle und die
steht unmittelbar bevor
schleswig-holstein dokumentiert wie man
es machen können wir haben hier die
dreijährige gewalt dort wo sie teddy
haben brauchen sie keinen kontakt nach
verfolgung mehr kann den masken mehr zu
tragen kann abstand mehr zu halten warum
infektionsschutz ist gefahren hat werder
nicht durchgelesen geimpft oder getestet
nachweise von michael keine gefahr aus
gibt es auch keine rechtliche grundlage
mehr an die maßnahmen fest werden sie
kommen ohne zu einer bedingung also dem
freedom day der freiheit das ist die
freiheitsrechte komplett zurückkehren
zur bedingung machen den
koalitionsgesprächen mit wem auch immer
kann zunächst einmal ist der
freiheitsstatue 26 19 da können die
menschen wählen beispielsweise freie
demokraten um dafür sorge zu tragen dass
wir schnellstmöglich einen normalen
verfassungsmäßigen zustand zurückkehren
es wird keine bedingung sein wir werden
massiv dafür kämpfen das haben wir auch
schon im deutschen bundestag gemacht die
pandemische lagen maximalbetrag weiter
aufzuheben die rechtliche basis macht
sich zu bedingungen gehen sie da rein
und sagen oder fritz mensch also erstmal
entweder weil ihr mit uns sprechen
wollte
wir werden sagen wir werden keine
maßnahmen hätten wir mittragen auch in
der koalition nicht die wir für
unverhältnismäßig hätten wir haben in
mehreren papieren mehreren
entschließungsanträgen des deutschen
bundestages dokumentiert was wir was wir
glauben und ich vermute mal dass das
problem bis wir eine koalition haben
sich ohnehin gelöst haben werden weil so
karl lauterbach sieht das sicherlich
anders dann spricht ja schon von dem
gefährlichen herbst und der
gesundheitsminister werden machen sie
zur bedingung das kann ich jetzt den
kollegen kann auch sehr wir haben in der
pandemie frage er aus medizinischer
sicht ist aus juristischer sicht in
weiten teilen völlig unterschiedliche
auffassungen trotzdem sagt einer der
wenigen mit dem er wirklich intensiv
diskutieren könne bin auch ganz
begeistert wenn er immer sagt ja gerade
noch mal eine neue studie gelesen ich
würde mir abends etwas anderes
vorstellen als nur studien zu lesen aber
da gehen die leute hier in der
stammkneipe auf carlotta bei ihnen nicht
nicht positiv was sagen die sonst
also man würde ihn morgen so sagen wir
packen oder duftmarke
hatte das sagen sie ja nicht nur hier
sondern das war es dann auch der war
auch also auch die maloche aus dem aus
leverkusen bochum da wo er kandidiert
sie sagen auch das ist keine von uns der
höhe hier dürfen die krähen wir dürfen
nicht fußballstadion
energiewende also aber unabhängig davon
wie gesagt er ist ein mensch mit dem man
wirklich gutes tut gut diskutieren
können was ich ja als vertreter der bank
fragen findet man sich in der sache
streiten sich persönlich zu sehr an die
wäsche zu gehen das ist unterentwickelt
bei uns in deutschland mittlerweile aber
noch einmal es wird keine bedingung aber
es noch einmal darum nicht das verstehen
wir
können doch nicht jetzt nicht dauernd
bedingungen und aufstehen und die anders
stellen bedingungen aufnehmen müssen
sich miteinander reden also entscheidend
ist wir müssen miteinander reden eins
ist jedenfalls klar die freien
demokraten werden dafür sorgen und dafür
werde ich so definitiv mein persönliches
versprechen als vorzugsweise als was
auch immer ich bin ja schnell von der
bundespolizei nahmen ein bad nehmen an
die gespräche liefen definitiv auch
teile und ich werde definitiv auch dafür
sorgen mit meiner partei dass wir
schnellstmöglich sagen rechtlichen
normalzustand zurückkehren zu einer
normalität die wir gewohnt und warum
sagen sie nicht an und dann meine dass
ich drei monate her dass die
[Musik]
johann stammt hat gesagt der dritte oder
also der fahrer sind der dritte oktober
soll es sein der gerade vom 30
ich will mich ja nicht auf eine taste
ich sage nur die menschen können am 26.9
durch ihre wahlentscheidung
dokumentieren was sie wollen da können
sich darauf verlassen dass die freien
demokraten mit mir an der spitze in
dieser frage das auch umsetzen werden
sie sehen dass in schleswig holstein wir
sind nicht weiter als alle andere wir
haben die pandemie besser als alle
anderen bewerkstelligen die hohe
impfzahlen gerade bei den älteren und
wir haben geringe inzidenz und warum
weil die leute selbst vernünftig sind
nur noch ihre gesundheit achten ich
selbst würde wenn ich jetzt in einen bus
steigen müsste immer noch eine maske
aufsetzen obwohl ich jetzt eigentlich
mental für überflüssig halte aber ich
werde sie immer noch aufsetzen aus
eigenschutz überlegung heraus ich habe
mich impfen dass sie nicht die konstanz
auf geh jetzt zu schützen sondern um
mich zu schützen weil ich jetzt weiß ich
muss keine angst haben wenn ich mich
infiziert vor allem schweren verlauf
oder verrannt und ist weil wenn die
leute das begreifen ist hat der gassen
recht als die dänen erklärt haben wir
heben alles auf in der woche ist dem
foto im markt drastisch angestiegen
warum wir die leute angefangen darüber
nachzudenken was ja nichts mehr also
schütze ich mich jetzt selbst vielleicht
sollten wir diesen versuch auch mal
wagen und was sagen in ihre leute hier
freue mich noch mal in strande an der
bar was sagen sie was sie machen sollen
bei corona schluss aus ende freedom day
oder ja also wir haben ja faktisch den
filialen der jetzt hier steht so
erscheinen ich akzeptiere dass dennoch
für eine übergangszeit desto mehr
vornehmen aber sie führen bei uns wenn
sie
wunderbar arena gegen zum handballspiel
thw ging es gleich weiter handewitt dann
können sie da rein gehen ohne dass wir
sie können die melander sitzen die
können wieder bier trinken und alles
mögliche sie müssen eben nur nachweisen
wie hier auch sind die ebenso getestet
ist hat sich hier reinkam dieses lokal
kann ja gesagt machen sie mal luca
eltern kontakt nach verfolgung weil es
keinen sinn macht wir müssen das nicht
mehr tun hat keiner gesagt setzen sie
bitte mal die maske auf sie würden hier
sogar schräg angeguckt werden wenn sie
in maske aufsetzen weil wir das gefühl
hatten sie seien vielleicht infiziert
und müssten sich der seite und uns an
geschützen also noch einmal der weg in
die freiheit ist geebnet und je
schneller wir den schlechten scheint
modell durch den bayerischen mit den
hohen incidence werden den hohen
todesfalls seien desto mehr haben die
leute wieder drauf dass sie für sich
selbst sorgen müssen dass sie
eigenverantwortlich ihre gesundheit und
dass die normalität nichts böses ist
wovor sie angst haben müssen sondern was
gut ist weil es gut macht auch wieder zu
leben zum abschluss wollen wir über das
thema patriotismus
sprechen herr kubicki über die frage was
eigentlich wollte noch deutsch ist
selbstverständlich ist dass die fahnder
unseres landes und das ist das symbol
einig der zusammengehörigkeit ich will
was ist deutsch im jahr 21
[Musik]
sehr interessante frage ich würde mal
sagen sie würden menschen aus bayern
anders beantworten als ich aber ich
würde mal vermuten jeweils war das
bisher meine vorstellung
dass deutsch geprägt wird dadurch dass
man dieses deutschland mittags schon
wein trinken oder nicht
also wenn es bisher nicht deutsch
gewesen sein sollte sondern
südeuropäischer finde ich die
einwanderung diesen europäischen lebens
bekommen angemessen
ich finde man kann wenn die uhr
zweistellig wird schon mal ein glas wein
trinken und sich daran freuen aber für
mich für mich ist deutschen nach wie vor
probleme zu bewältigen heranzugehen zu
tüfteln
disziplin zu haben damit meine ich nicht
rohstoff disziplin sein dass in wien
zusammen an einem an einer aufgabe zu
arbeiten bis sie bewältigt ist und nicht
mittendrin aufzuhören für mich gehört
mittlerweile auch eine gewisse form von
pünktlichkeit dazu weil das auch eine
frage von respekt ist über die mit dem
mit ihm verabredet habe früher hab ich
mir gesagt wer auf mich warten habe ich
nicht verdient mittlerweile war es eine
ziemlich arrogante herangehensweise war
weil ich ja man gegenüber damit
dokumentiere dass sie nicht nicht für so
wertvoll halten mich selbst seitdem sind
ich bin mittlerweile über pünktlich
meine frau findet ja schon
katastrophalen
seit zehn fünfzehn jahren ist es bei mir
so leid für mich auch ein ausdruck wie
gesagt dass das pack 2 es gegenüber es
ist und wie gesagt was ich was ich an
den deutschen seiten so schätze in der
vergangenheit ist wie gesagt die
tatsache
dass man sich nicht unterkriegen lässt
egal was passiert nicht sehr
niedergeschlagen wird steht wieder auf
und begriffen habe ich das erst als tor
nach gesagt habe welche riesenleistung
die generation meiner eltern der traktor
nach dem letzten krieg der war ja alles
kaputt wenn sich das angucken heute in
den ferien und 80 prozent zerstört
da sind die nicht tränen ausgebrochen
haben sich hingesetzt zweifel ist wie
gesagt wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
wieder aufbauen wenn ich das heute ihre
teilweise wie junge menschen darüber
empfinden wenn sie meine kleine
beeinträchtigung meine mutter hat immer
gesagt früher was was schwerbehindert du
hast mir kriegst du hast eine krise
nicht als wie aus dem krieg haben alles
weg war das war krise und da haben ja
nicht gesagt
wie vor zweifel jetzt sondern mit mir
viel schwerer ist dass die jungen leute
die einen schulstreik man doch lieber
intensiver lernen sollten weil die es
sein müssen die probleme gewählte gehen
und zwar nicht dadurch dass ich jetzt in
tränen ausbrechen also manchmal
die junge generation schlechthin hier
entstand da gibt es eine menge junger
menschen ist alles heraus man gute segel
erstanden hat vier olympiasieger beim
segeln gestellt die wollen dass die sind
teilweise an einer fachhochschule oder
in wirtschafts gymnasien die wollen dass
die sagen wir haben probleme mit
antriebssystemen einsetzen muss man
überlegen was sie besser machen können
das ist doch nicht besser
herangehensweise also weniger auf die
straße mehr juni ja mein reden mehr in
die uni mehr und mehr in die betriebe
und die probleme analysieren und
bewältigen etwas waren wir gerade in
afghanistan ist ein schlechtes beispiel
wenn sie in der welt unterwegs sind
gehen sie nach china geht es nach polen
gehen sie
in die usa da haben sie unglaublich
viele junge menschen die richtig bissig
sind die probleme des landes zu
bewältigen
dann müssen wir jetzt aufpassen dass wir
nicht unter fällen wir haben relativ
viel kreativität und vergleichsweise
weltweit vergleichsweise bildungsprozess
bildungssystem was nur noch besser
werden muss nutzen wir die chancen die
wir haben und verzweifelt wir nicht an
dem was für uns darf man stolz sein
deutschland zu sein selbstverständlich
darf man stolz sein es darf nicht
überheblich werden aber alle anderen
länder sind auch stolz haben sie eine
flagge zu hause selbstverständlich habe
eine schwäche oder startflagge ich hab
mir strand der flagge ich habe eine
holstein kiel 1 in deutschland und ich
habe eine deutschlandflagge die habe ich
auf hochgezogen als die grüne jugend bei
uns erklärte deutschlandflagge ist ist
ein journalist habe ich sie hochgezogen
und die größten likes bei mir bei
facebook als ich gesagt habe jetzt habe
ich aus protest alle deutschland flagge
nach oben gezogen aber ich mache das
auch immer wieder wenn die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft spielt immer
gewinnt und ich mache das genauso mit
der heuschreck tieflage in holstein kiel
ii gewinnt also man darf stolz auf sich
sein auch seine familie sagen das was
man selbst leistet man darauf stolz sein
auf die community in der man lebt und
auf die auf das land in dem man sieht
sind gartenzwerg ist spießig
aus meiner sicht schon ich will bei
kandidaten stellen habe ich akzeptiere
wenn menschen gartenzwergen e garten
stellen und hinten zu verschandeln sind
kleingärtner kleinbürgerlich
nein sie haben sich ein regelungen
geschaffen was sie in ihrer häuslichen
umgebung so nicht ich muss das nicht
weil ich sozusagen den garten vor der
türe oder den weit vor der tür über das
meer vor der tür haben wir wünschen
ihnen in den hochhäusern oder in
siedlungsgebieten wurden kann die
möglichkeit haben sich ein kleines stück
grünland zu verschaffen dann sollte aus
den kleingärten noch passieren was ist
dann am ende spießig und wer ist ein
spießbürger
ein spießbürger als e-mail der nicht
akzeptiert dass andere menschen anders
leben als er selbst so ein spießbürger
und was sie selbst spießig man sagen sie
menschen das ist spitze
wenn wir klar den stücke aufgezwungen
werden die ich nicht tragen will wenn
ich eingeladen werde und er steht dann
drinnen smoking ist pflicht denn finde
ich das ziemlich spießig kommen sie dann
anders
gelegentlich nicht immer aber
gelegentlich ist macht ja keinen sinn
dass vorher zu stören dass man konflikte
löst aber bei sehr guten freunden
passiert es dann tatsächlich da sie
anders kommen und das werden wir auch
akzeptiere ich gelte ohnehin als träger
und der vogel und auch
beratungsresistente sollen wir das
akzeptieren wie spricht man eine frau
heute noch richtig an ohne etwas falsch
zu machen mit dem namen am besten
und wie flirten richtig visualisiert
über die augen es geht alles über die
augen lächeln und man kann das sofort
sehen also
sie können die fotografen wie vorher
fotografiert hat fragen sie kann durch
ihre linse sehen ob ich mit ihr flirtete
oder ob ich nicht mit gefunden haben
sind ihre würde nein aber aus anderen
gründen nicht aber kai kraus als hier
ständen aber
wir haben es auch mal probiert man bei
früheren wahlkämpfen es hat sich nur
wenn ich manchmal bewährt gerade weil
die augen dann anders an der strahlen
wenn du das leiblich in der nähe war
wenn ich vor überführt wurde es ist
richtig dass das nächste kabinett 50 50
mit männern und frauen zusammen gesetzt
werden soll wie es zum beispiel oder
scholz möchte das ist sogar überwiegend
wahrscheinlich weil alle
parteien so wie ich das gesehen habe ein
großes interesse daran haben ein
geschlechterspezifisch ausgeglichen ist
kam er zur verfügung zu stellen
so bot es ist nämlich keine
vorbedingungen aber es ist ganz gut um
zu dokumentieren dass tatsächlich
gesellschaft zur hälfte aus männern und
frauen besteht und da in der
vergangenheit schon die qualität nicht
das zentrale kriterium war wie wir sehen
konnten weil viele minister nivea
altmaier mars und anderen
wird das nicht schlimmer hat es
deutschland verändert das 16 jahre eine
frau kannst dort war
nein sagt deutschland verändert dass in
den 16 jahren
die kanzlerin ist geschafft den eines zu
erwecken als legal ist bei ihren guten
händen und wir heute feststellen dass
wir 16 jahre nicht ausschließlich aber
überwiegend viele sachen verschlafen
waren die merkel ruhe hat uns nicht gut
getan wie läuft das ab wenn sie sich mit
der kanzlerin begegnet im bundestag zum
beispiel weil sie haben ja mal gerne
einen raus gegensatz zu dem match musste
das denn schon sein oder lion soll weiß
ich weiß dass ich die respektiere sie
weiß auch dass nicht alles falsch war
ein irrer in ihrer amtszeit also wir
hätten die finanzkrise ohne das
zusammenspiel von angela merkel und
verstanden wird so nicht bewältigt in
deutschland muss man einfach neidlos
anerkennen ich hätte mich 2050 etwas
anders verhalten als sie gewöhnlich ist
wirklich respektiere dass sie auch nicht
monetären gründen das nehme ich ihr habt
nicht mit anschauen wollten die leute
einen an zaun stehen der greifen zu
grunde gehen das ist auch schwer zu
ertragen ich bin auch einer der
unterzeichner des appells gerade immer
wenn man von der see kommt kann man
akzeptieren dass menschen in mehr
trinken das darf nicht sein aber sie hat
eine eine ruhe sozusagen über das land
verbreitet die sehr viel potenzial
vernachlässigt und vernichtete wir sind
im digitalen bereich mittlerweile so
weit
erreicht werden dass es schwer werden
wird das in den nächsten jahren wirklich
aufzuholen mit großer geschwindigkeit
wir sind von 20 staaten wo ist die hier
auf platz 17 wir sind in europa auf
platz neun ist jetzt mal vorstellen dass
noch überholt das gedacht und nicht
sagen wir haben bei der frage der
leistungsbereitschaft der kreativität an
schulen und hochschulen hat die wo
nachholbedarf bei der infrastruktur
haben wir in einen riesigen
nachholbedarf und auch bei den
zukunftsfragen nicht klimawandel
bewältigung war die politik der
kanzlerin seit 2002 waren die man darauf
ausgerichtet zu beruhigen stadt
anzuschauen finden sie dann lieber mit
armin laschet oder oder scholz kommt zum
abschluss sein publik und jetzt mal
festlegen ich würde lieber die lasche
kollegen das ist kein geheimnis dass wir
dauernd wir sind weil sie glauben nicht
mehr daran sich an der die haben eine
sehr sehr starke eine sehr starke
präferenz für jamaika definitiv auch
wenn der platz zwei
müssen wir versuchen dass das auszuloten
wie haben wäre mehrere
koalitionen bundesweit uns die bremen
ist brauchst du das blieb nicht nicht
weit vorne weg und
wir haben in der bundespolizei erlebt
das 1976 habe ich persönlich noch erlebt
die cdu kurs von absolute mehrheit bauen
fragst du dich nicht in kassel gestellt
hatten die sozialliberale größten
fortgesetzt wurde aber es wird später
das bestimmt nicht nur zweifel wir sind
das bestimmt wenn zweifel bestehen
die union und die un die grünen ist wird
auf die grünen angekommen worauf sich
diesmal viel einlassen würden es wird
überhaupt auf die wurden und uns
angekommen habe ich sehr dafür plädieren
dass wir uns zunächst am wahlabend mal
zusammen oder danach zusammensetzen um
zu gucken was geht überhaupt denn wenn
wir beide jeweils ausschließen also wir
schließen jetzt die ampel draußen
schließen jamaika aus dann gnade
deutschland gott dann dürfen wir so
lange wählen bis wir ein neues wolken
herzlichen dank wolfgang kubicki fdp
vize herzlichen dank dass wir hier sein
dürfen in ihrem heimatort in stand der
herzlichen dank für das xxl interview
für das schwarz-rot-goldene interview zu
den fragen die bislang noch nicht
gestellt wurden und damit zurück von
hier aus nach berlin